[Vsauce 2]
Hot dog stuffed pizza crust
and a portable GameCube
encased in Tupperware.
Vsauce, Kevin here.
this is Mind Blow.
Carkoon is a car seat
that wraps the child
in a protective shell—
the airbag is made of Kevlar
and fireproof material,
providing 20 minutes
of protection
from a blaze.
There's also a transmitter
and GPS
that sends signals
to a monitoring station
to alert emergency services.
To aid in communication
for deaf/blind people,
there's the Mobile Lorm Glove
The Design Research Lab in Berlin
is developing this device
to translate Lorm,
a common form of communication
used by people with hearing
and vision impairment
into digital text.
The pressure-sensitive glove
allows message input,
and you can also text to the glove,
which the user receives
through a vibro-tactile feedback pattern.
Robotic rings are less life altering
and more or less just for fun.
A microcontroller and computer
move the eyes and mouth,
and they're looking
to further develop the rings
so they actually react
to the motion of the wearer.
Reacting to the behavior of inmates
is the mood-sensing Robot Prison Guard.
Developed in South Korea,
it has 3D cameras
and software designed to analyze
abnormal prison activity.
It relays the information
to a control room,
and also allows the human guard
to communicate
through the robot.
Let's take a break from robots
and lose some weight.
The K-E diet promises
20 pounds of weight loss
in just ten days
simply by eating through your nose.
A feeding tube is put
up the nose and into the stomach,
pumping 800 calories worth
of protein, fat, and water on a slow drip.
It induces ketosis,
which tricks the body
into burning fat, and it costs
$1,500 dollars a day.
If you prefer eating
elevator wall cookies,
just ride the lickable lift.
A London-based company installed
this Willy Wonka-inspired elevator
that uses 1,325 cookies.
Oh, and once a cookie is licked,
it's removed by the bellboy.
So, yeah.
Breaking their own world record,
the Purdue Society of Professional Engineers team
created a 300-step Rube Goldberg machine.
The simple task of blowing up
and popping a balloon
took the team 5,000 hours
to construct,
and includes peeling an apple,
making a hamburger,
and changing a lightbulb.
Back to robots,
DARPA and Boston Dynamics
would like you to meet Pet Man,
a walking, crouching,
push-up performing robot,
and they also have a biped
that successfully goes up stairs.
Don't worry, there are
also octopus robots in development.
Funded by the European Commission,
the Octopus Project
features shape memory alloy tentacles
in the front
and silicone arms in the back.
Finally, here's a huge Star Wars-themed
Lego barrel organ
playing the main theme
from Star Wars.
[♪ Star Wars theme ♪]
[♪ Star Wars Theme continues ♪]
I'm going to leave you
with an earthquake-proof table,
and as always, thanks for watching.
[♪ music ♪]
[1 tonne]
[Japanese Maneki
Neko cat figurines]
[♪ music ♪]
[♪ music continues ♪]
[Vsauce 2]